on the Nobel Prize talks podcast are we
the only ones here in the universe there
is it's planted the only one that's
alive John metha or are there many
planets that are alive I'll tell you my
prediction is that wherever there's
liquid water third light in conversation
with me Adam Smith that might think what
I think how would we know well we have
to go a few places where you can examine
this so on Mars theory at least was and
probably still is liquid water in places
so I think them when we dig carefully
and well we will discover assigned with
life on Mars have a listen to the
podcast on that well priced at ugh
iTunes and on Android devices